so there are lot of divisions on the
left not often aired in public but they
do disagree with each other if there's
one issue that unites almost everybody
on that side though its immigration and
the principle they've united behind is
that anybody from anywhere on the globe
should be allowed to come into the
United States no questions asked if you
don't believe that pay attention for
example look at the theater surrounded
the recent migrant Caravan all of this
for a group of people a lot of whom are
mothers and children who pose no
imminent threat the brother you knighted
States has decided that a couple of
thousand scared sick you know people
fleeing violence are a bigger threat to
the United States then Isis guess what
man it's in our laws that people are
allowed to come to our borders and ask
for asylum
so this is a new thing it seems like
they've always had this view but no many
the lift left used to be skeptical of
massive immigration partly for economic
reasons because it undermined the wages
of workers but there were others many
others who had environmental concerns
too about letting a lot more people into
the country so Cafaro is the author of
how many is too many the progressive
argument to reducing immigration into
the United States and he joins us a mr.
Farr thank you very much for coming on
having you is the result of a long
nationwide search to find someone with
your views because I remember so well as
a kid that Democrats were really
concerned some were liberals about
overpopulation and the effects on the
natural environment and I always kind of
agreed with that tell me your concerns
about mass immigration and its effect on
the environment well Tucker I'm not sure
on the last liberal in in the country
who's concerned about immigration driven
population growth but we are a minority
among environmentalists I'll give you
that so I see like the Sierra Club which
used to care about the Sierras huge fire
breaks out in the Sierras last summer
started inadvertently by an illegal
immigrant or the the degradation of
marijuana farming in Northern California
which really does poison the soil and
they say literally nothing because
they're concerned for open borders
overrides their concern for the
environment what is that about well I
think you're absolutely right if you go
back to the the birth of the
environmental move
5060 years ago there was so much concern
and focus on population issues because
people saw the connections between
overuse of resources between too much
pollution and and the sheer numbers of
people and and environmentalists used to
talk about that I think what happened
between then and now is back then most
of our population growth was coming from
the number of children we were having
Native Americans
whereas today population growth in the
u.s. is primarily driven by high levels
of immigration
so people for whatever reason weren't as
comfortable saying we needed to limit
immigration as they were saying we need
to limit how many how many kids we have
I think that's a mistake though because
either way you're driving population
growth and that has environmental
consequences so quickly I wish we had
more time for this because I think it's
fasting and I would urge people to buy
your book on this what's the response
you get from your fellow liberals when
use when you say wait a second you know
there are environmental effects of
letting all these people in what do they
say to you well mostly what I get are
our people who most people say well I
didn't realize that I hadn't thought
about that because as you say
environmentalists have stopped talking
about it but the responses really run
the gamut from you know how long have
you been a racist too
oh thank you so much for talking about
that I've I've been thinking that myself
and and I'm just not comfortable talking
about it exact so it's an interesting
thing to talk and write about because
you do get such a wide range of
responses yeah I mean you spend a week
in a crowded dirty country and you'll
find out you don't want to live in a
place like that I think thank you very
much for your positions that explain
them to us thanks for having me Tucker I
appreciate it